nos dice en cuenta las ballenas escriben
los números que faltan en los cuadros
bueno aquí tenemos las ballenas y aquí
están los números que les corresponden
entonces aquí tenemos una ballena esta
es la segunda ballena es la ballena
número 2 aquí ponemos el número que nos
falta luego sigue la ballena número 3
la ballena número 4 y esta es la ballena
número 5 vamos a comprobar la respuesta
es correcta vamos a resolver otra
pregunta ahora nos dice cómo contamos
los ratones bueno aquí tenemos que este
es el primer ratón y tiene un 1 este es
el segundo ratón tiene un 2 para bien
ese es el tercer ratón aquí hay un 3
cuarto ratón el número 4 quinto ratón el
número 5 sexto ratón el número 6 y
séptimo ratón el número 7 este conteo es
correcto a ver en cambio este tenemos un
ratón el primer ratón número 1
y el segundo ratón tiene el número 3
esto no es correcto se saltaron el
número 2 luego sigue el ratón 3 pero
tiene un número 5 y debería ser el reto
número 3 así que este conteo está mal
así no es como se cuentan contamos 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 así en orden esto es cómo
contamos los ratones y comprobamos
nuestra respuesta
es correcta vamos a resolver otro
ejercicio
ahora vamos a contar ardillas como las
contamos bueno vemos que aquí está una
ardilla un 12 ardillas el 2 3 ardillas 3
4 ardillas el número 4 5 ardillas en el
número 56 ardillas el número 6 7
ardillas el número 7 8 ardillas el
número 8 9 ardillas el número 9 este
está bien el conteo vamos a ver este
otro empezamos con una ardilla está bien
12 ardillas 2 3 ardillas
el 3 4 ardillas el 4 va bien 5 ardillas
el número 5 y aquí tenemos 6 ardillas
pero está el número 7 y aquí tenemos 6
ardillas pero tienen el número 7 aquí ya
está mal
esta es la villa número 6 no es 7 se
saltaron un número y luego sigue la
ardilla número 7 pero tiene el 8
tenemos aquí esta villa que debería ser
la número 8 pero es la número 10 aquí no
estamos contando bien las ardillas aquí
sí vamos a comprobar la respuesta muy
bien hagamos otro problema más ahora
contamos ballenas como las contamos
tenemos una ballena en uno muy bien
tenemos dos ballenas el dos está bien
tenemos tres ballenas y aquí está el
número tres esto está muy bien aquí
abajo tenemos una ballena huy pero nos
pusieron el número dos pues no así no
podemos contar aquí tenemos dos ballenas
pero nos ponen que es el número cuatro
no pues definitivamente esta es
incorrecta así es como contamos las
ballenas elegimos este comprobamos
respuestas
es correcta hagamos otro problema
ahora nos toca contar las flores y vemos
que tenemos una flor en uno tenemos dos
flores 2 3 flores 3 y aquí hay 4 flores
pero no la contaron se la saltaron ahora
este es la flor número 5 pero tiene un 4
lo cual está mal
esta es la flor número 6 y tiene un 5
aquí esta es la flor número 7 tiene un 6
que no es correcto y aquí hay otra flor
que debería ser la 8 pero tampoco está
contabilizada se le asaltaron y está me
dicen que es la flor número 7 cuando
debe ser la flor número 9 así que esto
está mal así no se cuenta se cuenta 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 flores
esta es la correcta comprobamos
respuesta y en efecto hagamos una más
como contamos las bellotas tenemos una
bellota aquí un uno bien tenemos dos
bellotas y aquellos dos aquí abajo
tenemos una bellota y está bien el uno
aquí tenemos dos bellotas pero tenemos
un tres y no esto no es correcto esta es
la respuesta correcta comprobamos la
respuesta y es la correcta